setting the stage for the final dress
rehearsal tonight they're performing the
bartered bride by Samanta a favorite in
the shreelane theatres repertoire opera
director Luton dem makes sure
everything's going well I was born in
heaven and I went to school here in 1992
I left for college because unfortunately
there's no University in Spain in 2000 I
came back from the Rhineland full of
enthusiasm for my hometown I liked
ravines northern German serenity high
quality of life and the fact that it's
not so big we're gone to the shave stat
district and then to other places and
the great thing is we can do it all on
foot it takes him to them just about
five minutes to walk to shostats a
second historical district in addition
to the old town
this coveted residential area has many
well-preserved buildings and plenty of
small shops that sell unusual items
you think it the listen we're now in
sheffster it's a lovingly restored
district where I grew up and feel at
home especially in the chef church where
we're going now the shelf Church of st.
Nicholas is an 18th century baroque
brick church
it contains the Crypt where shredding
zukul families are buried until Em's
life is closely linked to the church she
sang in the children's choir and learned
to play the organ here it's where she
married and where her children were
baptized the way to her next
recommendation takes woudl em through
the harbor district
on the small island of chuan and host
stands one of the city's most beautiful
buildings the Ziggler hime restaurant it
was the boathouse of the traditional
Schwerin sailing club in 1999 it was
reconstructed based on the original
plans
captain issuance I have one of the best
jobs ever I can go to the theater every
day and if I do need a break I can get
to the Ziggler home in five minutes have
a coffee and relax
Cuffy woman on TV a bomb in lesson
you think I'd left and we're now on the
other side of Lakes ravine on consoles
and baked it means Frenchman's way
because it was built by French prisoners
of war from 1870 to 71 it links the
palace garden with our city beach and
sipping daf and it has beautiful villas
a fantastic view over the water and an
especially dreamy spot that I want to
show you these needs the same question
from principles and make a wooden
walkway takes you through a moorland
forest - ooh - lems third tip a small
headland called a DuBose Ness low german
for a storks beak
it's an unspoiled natural paradise right
on leaks berry
out of US needs this lot of a sneeze is
only about a 20 minute walk from the
palace but you're in the middle of
nature here in a meadow of orchids and
other rare plants at the same time you
have a gorgeous view of the city's most
beautiful buildings
you